almost one in three American women will
have an abortion at some point in their
lives but even though the Supreme Court
made it legal in 1973 states have been
having a party with restrictions since
then testing the limits of federal law
states usually allow abortions when
life-threatening health issues are
involved or in cases of rape or incest
but otherwise there are a lot of
obstacles here are some of the biggest
ones women face when it comes to getting
an abortion as a matter of personal
choice obstacle number one age if you're
under 18 lots of states require that a
parent gets notified if you want an
abortion and some require that a parent
gives their consent in eight states mom
or dad even has to provide a written
letter of consent that's been notarized
going further several states require
that both parents get notified or give
consent but young women who don't want
to tell their rights don't have to in
these states obstacle to time legally
even just a week can make a huge
difference
18 states ban abortion passed somewhere
between 20 and 26 weeks of pregnancy
which is measured from the date of your
last period abortions before 13 weeks
the first trimester are the most common
and the least restricted and abortions
past 26 weeks in the third trimester are
extremely rare there are only four known
doctors in the country who perform them
obstacle three money the average cost of
a first trimester abortion nationwide is
451 dollars but it can range between 300
and 950 if you have private insurance
there's a chance it could cover the
procedure we talked to dr. Elena Saldana
cough director of women's health policy
for the Kaiser Family Foundation and she
said that many states actually forced
private insurers not to cover abortion
and the best way to find out if your
policy does is to ask on the other hand
women who have Medicaid are covered for
an abortion in these 16 states elsewhere
some states not only been Medicaid and
private insurers from covering it they
also forced Obama care insurers not to
cover abortions either but there are
some other ways to pay salgan Acuff said
many clinics offer help on a
case-by-case basis and she also
mentioned the national network of
abortion funds which helps foot the bill
for women who can't afford it
obstacle for finding a clinic or doctor
it could be pretty tough to find the
clinic if you live in one of these
states each state has only three
abortion providers or less Elizabeth
Nash who works at the Guttmacher
Institute which collects abortion data
says one of the best resources for
finding clinics is the National Abortion
Federation hotline they have a
comprehensive list of all abortion
providers in the country obstacle 5
waiting and getting a talking-to in
several states women have to visit a
clinic twice the first time so they can
get a lecture the second time for the
actual abortion in 26 states women are
also required to review state prepared
materials on abortion that may or may
not be all that factual like in Indiana
where a woman is told that the fetus can
feel pain before 22 weeks women may even
be referred to so called crisis
pregnancy centers designed to convince
them not to get an abortion and finally
in 13 states women need to get an
ultrasound before the actual procedure
and in three of those states women are
required to look at the image
as you've probably gathered at this
point it's complicated and confusing
often by design but broadly speaking
it's hardest to get an abortion in Texas
Mississippi North Dakota and South
Dakota who makes it easiest California
New York and Washington State even just
getting the facts on abortion in the US
can be an uphill battle but the more
knowledge you have about the laws in
your states the better
person who is really about abortion and
a woman's right to have one PS that
right was granted by the Supreme Court
back in 1973 but the show must go